dj ashba has had a very busy 2020 good
for him over the summer he released
hypnotic
in the fall he released less dance and
now he has a brand new christmas song
jc got to talk to him about his new
project so let's check it out
asheville buddy and it's so good to see
you how are you i'm good man how are you
fantastic uh you know the holiday season
is upon us and you have put together
this song which is it's like a mashup of
holiday goodness
we're talking about a christmas storm
what inspired you to do a christmas song
you know i i i love christmas more than
anything i'm the
i listen to christmas songs literally in
july
my when i met my wife i had a christmas
tree up for the entire year i just love
it like christmas music to me
maybe it takes me back to when i was a
kid i'm not sure but i just i love
the feel it gives me and and i've never
done really a christmas song
um since i did the one with neil diamond
so
this is the first one i uh did on my own
so yeah it's exciting
how did you pick is when you listen to
the song and the music video comes out
tonight i can't wait to see the video
tonight
but when you listen to the song it's a
mashup of all these great
familiar christmas songs how did you
pick the songs to use in your song
you know it was i i went through
hundreds of christmas songs and
there was a lot of stipulations you know
one you know basically key changes how
i'm gonna really
morph these in you know and it was a lot
of work but
you know the four i picked were just
some of my favorite
christmas songs out there and i just
wanted to really you know kind of
morph them together and make this just a
beautiful piece of music for
people for many years to come hopefully
so
you were kind to us kind enough over the
summer to have us out there for the
filming of hypnotic the music video for
that and that was one of the highlights
of my year being out there for that
can you give us a tease or a taste of
what to expect with the music video
yeah so um it's gonna open up with a
little girl by a christmas tree and it's
all about giving hope like to you know
kids and we tied this whole
uh video and song into toys for tots
national
which is really cool so i figured we
could take this song and do something
good because
as you guys know uh it's been a tough
year for everybody out there
and i think you know this is my way of
being able to kind of help and give back
a little bit
and uh so on the video launch tonight
there'll be a donate
to toys for tots button and all the
merch i'm giving
50 of all the merch sells to uh
to toys for tots for this when you were
a kid what was that
was there a must-have toy that you that
you wanted and maybe santa didn't bring
it for you or maybe brought you a
different version or maybe he did
deliver that toy
what was it for you um it was a bb gun
yeah and i got it and then i shot the
window out at the gas station down the
corner and they took it away
that's like yeah i was like six
you know six years old with a bb gun you
didn't shoot your eye out though did you
no but i was a good aim because i was
aiming at the window at the gas station
and i got it
but uh what did i know you know oh no
thank you so much jc for that las vegas
now exclusive we love hearing from dj
ash but you can check out
ashford's new music video a christmas
storm tonight at nine
now let's send it over to sherry with a
look at your most accurate weather now
forecast